qui est sûr c'est que pour les états
unis on assiste au début d'une invasion
de l'ukraine joe biden l'a dit il ne
ferme pas pour autant la porte du
dialogue avec moscou mais il annonce à
un premier train de sanctions et
prévient que l'ensemble du secteur
bancaire russe pourrait être visé si la
russie allait plus loin on fait le point
sur ces sanctions américaines avec notre
correspondante à washington sonia dridi
joe biden a dans son discours dénoncé le
début d'une invasion russe de l'ukraine
est une violation flagrante du droit
international
la maison blanche hausse le ton alors
qu'au départ elle est restée prudente
après l'allocution de vladimir poutine
lundi elle n'a pas tout de suite utilisé
le terme invasion alors en riposte le
président américain a annoncé une série
de sanctions des sanctions contre des
banques russes mais aussi contre la
dette souveraine ruse pour couper la
russie de tout financement occidentaux
joe biden également annoncé des
sanctions contre les élites russes et
leurs familles il a notamment déclaré il
partage les gains illicites des
politiques du kremlin ils doivent
également partager la douleur donc le
président américain qui a adopté un ton
ferme dont ce discours et il a prévenu
qu'une attaque militaire massif de
l'ukraine était possible et que et bien
dans ce cas là les états unis pourrait
annoncer de nouvelles sanctions allaient
au delà de ces sanctions déjà annoncé le
président américain qui a également
déclaré que face à la menace d'une
attaque russe et bien les états unis
allaient continuer de soutenir le cren
militairement washington a également
annoncé le redéploiement des troupes
américaines dans les pays baltes joe
biden a précisé que c'était une action
défensive il a déclaré nous n'avons pas
l'intention de combattre la russie coup